after the Honest Trailer check out the
educational song we made to help
memorize the names of all of that guy
character actors Christopher McDonald
Shooter McGavin is right on the
tits and evil Breakfast Club principle
that guy's name is pugly son Link in the
description below
[Music]
you've seen Ezra Miller star in bar
fights restraining orders grooming
allegations felony burglaries and
chokeslam videos
now see the film that dares you to
wonder what dirt Ezra has on Warner
Brothers because this is basically
confession tape
professional the Justice League is not
very good at that part yet trust me
The Flash
before James Gunn reboots the DC
Cinematic Universe for the sixth time
seventh and I lost count glim to the
Finish Line with his colossal screw-up
all about a colossal screw-up I am
pretty obnoxious that's burned through
directors like the weed on Ezra's Ranch
where they found a one-year-old with a
bullet in her mouth allegedly and
introduces the concept of the Multiverse
about 10 years too late to be
interesting he's Gonna Save The
Multiverse yeah man then the Multiverse
there are an infinite number of people
who know Peter Parker is Spider-Man can
show me the fate of every single World
about infinite Multiverse the Warner
Brothers server verse that's almost
self-aware about how sloppy and stale
the concept is wallpapers
what it is it's a hot mess but that
won't stop them from using it to defile
the corpse of some Legends to make a
quick buck
it's enough to make you lose faith in
humanity oh Faith restored rare W
Humanity rare W what do you do when your
star goes on a massive crime spree cast
them twice wait that can be right three
times what is going on Barry Allen one
is a whiny little thanks for saving me
from the sinkhole Flash and I'm starving
and curly hair girl isn't here and her
name is Sarah and she has a boyfriend
you hear that that's my stomach but
after his mom is murdered by someone I
guess Barry who works in a forensic
crime lab didn't bother to check in on
that part he'll reverse time and meet
Barry Allen too where growing up with
two parents somehow made him more
obnoxious
oh
and whiny great when you're leaving me
and now the storm's gonna ruin my day
what is this hell now I'm probably gonna
have to move why is it so cold it's the
Arctic fairy okay and the space Giant
and mistress murder our responsibility
too I was just doing my laundry you're
the one who came and told me that I'm a
superhero what are you doing would you
stop whining and gross
it's a bit more loose it hurts
you know where it hurts
in my dick okay was Grant Gustin that
unavailable I'm a Christopher Plummer
Weird Al but Barry's not alone and thank
goodness because two and a half hours of
this would be a war crime you don't stop
talking it's not Charming it's abrasive
and exhausting Michael Keaton is back as
a very 71 year old Batman this might
hurt when he's not playing the hits with
all the enthusiasm of Smash Mouth at a
County Fair I'm Batman how much do you
weigh you want to get nuts
let's get nuts they're dressing him up
like Rosie the Riveter and making him
eat repeatedly exactly
which is a weird choice for a film that
clearly wants to be a bad man movie
instead they even go full Clooney Tunes
at the end
foreign
verse now that feels earned cool party
when Barry forgets that General Zod
attacked the day after he got his powers
shift gears into a Supergirl Rescue
Mission briefly
Sasha cow comes to save the day both in
the movie and outside of it since Ezra
was presumably locked in the WB water
tower for the entire press tour in this
brand new take on a Kryptonian a grim
tortured Soul who questions whether
humanity is even worth fighting for oh
right well this time baby soups got
snuffed out in his crib so it's even
Grimmer the infant did not survive
so strap in for a mostly animated film
that looks like it was rendered on a
GameCube with the least realistic baby
since Clint Eastwood's prop guy took a
sick day featuring monstrous digital
stand-ins
huge balls of ghoulish fan service for
40 year olds and the first Hollywood
action climax set entirely on a Halo 3
map you know I'm starting to think all
the Warner Brothers is elaborate tax
write-off now like the producers under
the right circumstances a producer could
make more money with a flop than he
could with a hit or Infinity train or
bad girl or phase five or
starring The Perks of Being a wall facer
beers beers beers Naked and Afraid let's
do the time warp again I'm not sure what
I'm doing here something to do with the
flash I think Been There Done That I Am
Sasha Fierce nap before Zod what exactly
would you say it as you do here E2 Mama
I'm dead West Side Story Superman the
quest to rest in peace face looks off
galga Cameo Curry worst and this is what
a 200 million dollar movie looks like
now I guess
the flop
[Music]
if three flashes three Batman four
kryptonians Aquaman and one Roman can
drive ticket sales Warner Brothers is
going to need a new hero to save the box
office Come on Barbie
let's go party
Bingo thanks for watching and if you've
made it this far why not keep the party
going with our musical guide to all the
best that guy character actors click the
thumbnail on the right to watch now
spines Pines Pine I am skipping with
your spine I'm just Ken and I'm enough
and I'm great at doing stuff
I've Got a Lovely Bunch of Coconuts
I am Batman
[Laughter]